sachez que l' ocde prévoit une récession
mondiales d'au moins 6 % pour 2020
situation économique est précaire
partout en france le gouvernement va
présenter un troisième projet de loi un
projet de loi de finances secteurs les
plus fragilisées par la crise sanitaire
seront notamment soutenu 45 milliards
d'euros
on leur être alloué un gouvernement qui
planche sur un autre sujet la fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire à partir du
10 juillet pour autant plusieurs de ces
mesures pourrait être prolongé un
conseil des ministres donc très chargé
on en parle avec notre reporter mona
amoudé l'or devant l'elysée voilà bon
jour là vous êtes devant l'elysée le
gouvernement ne prolongera donc pas
l'état d'urgence sanitaire au delà du 10
juillet
et en effet amira il ne sera pas
prolongé au-delà du 10 juillet il ne
sera donc plus possible d'envisager un
recond finement et à titre d'exemple il
sera plus envisageable par exemple
d'interdire une manifestation pour des
raisons sanitaires et bayal macron et
edouard philippe ont tranché estime que
désormais une épidémie de couronnes à
virus est sous contrôle le gouvernement
veut tout de même rester prudents
puisque ce matin un nouveau projet de
loi va être présenté par le ministre de
la santé
olivier véran cette nouvelle loi
permettra à l'état de restreindre
l'offre de transport d'aménager à la
circulation des personnes et de
peut-être devoir fermer certains lieux
publics un projet de loi qui va être
présenté et voté à l'assemblée le 17
juin prochain et autres elle symbole de
la cette crise sanitaire qui s'achètent
l'exécutif
elle va annoncer que les municipales le
second tour en l'occurrence aura bien
lieu le 28 juin prochain et lors de ce
conseil des ministres il sera également
question deux budgets et d'argent
puisque le gouvernement va examiner un
nouveau un budget de crise
en tout 4 160 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir par exemple le secteur de
l'automobile de l'aéronautique ou encore
du tourisme alors que se profilent
faillite et licenciements pour certain
le gouvernement veut également renforcer
le budget du chômage partiel notamment
de 5 milliards de dollars même si
certains secteurs celle-ci mettre les
grands
lle de cette crise comme les transports
ou encore l'agriculture c'est donc
beaucoup à d'argent qui va gonfler la
dette publique de 120 1,9 pour cent mona
merci pour toutes ces précisions